en forme quand même une bonne équipe on
est faux mais comme on faisait une
question est oui tiens volant est pas
moi tout le monde va entrer dans une
nouvelle ère grâce à moi
et moi le patron et moi le backcourt
[Musique]
prenez aéro sympa et trop bien sapés
sais quelle matière je sais pas mais en
tout cas ça gratte mettons lui dans les
pattes un dénommé fantasio et nous
sommes sûrs non mais c'est pas un surnom
ajoutons un scientifique un peu farfelu
comte de champignac nous belle histoire
d'amour fort sicra et non c'est la
gonflette cotnam je peux le faire aussi
un ta gueule un écureuil globe trotter
spip tibet blanc oui spip spirou c'est
comme moi on est en cours et un méchant
très méchant et moi le patron c'est moi
le patron je serai pas un petit complexe
d'infériorité sa 21 février
préparez vous à une grande aventure
encore raté toi tu avais dit de les
chauffer quand il était là
enfin quand même une bonne équipe tous
les deux
[Musique]